tami Bruce is a radio show host in New
York City she's thought a lot about this
and she joins us now hey there hey Timmy
so how long before Eric Schneiderman's
alleged abuses become the abuse of all
men this is really a macro problem
shouldn't we pause before we shift
responsibility to everyone and ask who
knew about this specific guy yes I mean
look this is still it's sinking in it is
so horrific it's one thing to be arguing
about sexual harassment and treating
women badly or unequally in the
workplace that's bad enough these are
stories of physical violence of domestic
violence which has not been dealt with a
great deal when it comes to the me2
movement and a man who had was was law
enforcement I mean the Attorney General
of the state and it's an extraordinary
dynamic and we know that these issues
transcend politics and parties but
what's fascinating here is that these
are men whether it's Harvey Weinstein or
Bill Clinton or the Kennedys or now this
man who wrapped themselves in the cloak
of the me2 movement of feminism who said
that they were the champions for women
and ended up being the man that they
were warning everyone about and the
problem is as we as you mentioned in the
Ronan story is that for women on the
Left liberal women have been told and
effectively conditioned that you've got
to effectively give up yourself in a way
in order to be able to help the movement
or help the liberal narrative that
ironically these women were told by
their friends or even decided themselves
in one case that that they would put up
with this because he was too important
that that the argument that we want to
fight to protect women that we are going
to protect a man who is violent toward
them there's got to be this is one thing
to expose them but liberal women have to
ask themselves what other lies have we
been told what what are the things that
we've been told to how to behave what we
should sacrifice ourselves for and
here's the other revelation here Tucker
Schneiderman expected in some ways we
believe to be part of Hillary Clinton's
administration Weinstein in some reports
of course was her best friend and very
close to her the thing that has made
all of this possible to to come out
besides Ronin Pharaohs great reporting
and and other individuals as well like
Jane Mayer in this report is the fact
that Hillary Clinton lost if she had won
all of these people would have been
concealed protected and they would have
still been victimizing women in in many
industries but certainly this this
upper-crust
of the liberal framework with men and
the women that have protected them would
have continued to victimize women and
now we're at a point where it's about
really I content in this framework this
largeness of it is that it's about the
liberal ideology that that the the right
has been so demonized that you've got to
protect everyone in your realm because
it's the right and conservatives who are
supposed to be the deadly no I think
that soon and it's your own victimizers
there on the Left no enemies on the left
I've seen this all my life
yeah the sit and you're absolutely right
to say that there are creepy people on
both sides that's for sure but there's
one strain of this behavior that really
is particularly the left and that's the
overweening hypocrisy we're all
hypocrites I get it
but the idea that the guy who's telling
you you can't have a wood stove because
of its carbon emissions is flying in a
private jet or the person says you can't
have a gun has an armed bodyguard where
the me2 activist is beating up women
normal people wouldn't be that
hypocritical without hating them like no
people couldn't do that look you know
what I'm gonna pick another issue I know
I'm beating up women so I'm not gonna be
like the me to spokesman but liberals do
that again and again why what's that I
would contend that they actually they
don't believe in the issues they do any
more than Barack Obama cared about your
health care or getting rid of nuclear
weapons or Isis these are mechanisms for
their own power they use them and on the
left you get protected because you're
you've already convinced everyone else
that you're not the enemy so I don't
believe it's hypocrisy because to be a
hypocrite I suppose you have to kind of
sort of believe in the issue and then do
the opposite really they don't really
believe in it and and this is this is
our problem and that's the liberal
problem now is that has this just been a
game does no one believe in the issues
and for the women that have believed in
it let this at least hopefully maybe be
a crack you want to broken the glass
ceiling
it is it is only happening because
Hillary Clinton lost and now there's a
chance - for liberals to be honest and
maybe it's the Kanye West theory maybe
they can have free our minds which will
lead to safer lives and genuine
independence which is what liberals and
conservatives all Americans genuinely
want together we can stop alienating
ourselves from each other and come
together for the things that we have in
common
I've said it before you're a very deep
person Tammy thank you for that
Thank You Terry I appreciate it